oh I mean the rangas have been getting a
worse and worse deal inside my MA there
was 700,000 odd of them Muslims in a
majority Buddhist state and you know
Buddhism in my Martha various complex
reasons has gotten rather radicalized
it's typically a very liberal tolerant
faith but some tough monks and changes
in the political context of the country
have really combined to mean that this
group who've never had a good deal in
the country I felt more threatened more
marginalized more discriminated against
in in recent years and in the past we've
seen me I'm not say that of a
humanitarian aid now but no mention of
actually given these people more right
to actually v8 in a situation get any of
its neighbors actually Paul pressure on
whatever it is very tough because man
Mars never even accepted that this is a
group with long roots in the country
they claim their recent Bengali migrants
and you know some of them did come in
during the period of British rule when
these adjacent territories were were
managed together by the British but some
of them come from much further back
historically centuries back and and so
you know the fact that now they're being
denied political rights that you know in
the recent census they weren't even
allowed to identify themselves as ringa
means that you know it's very
problematic to see where the political
solution is going to come from and and
yet without it this will remain a
running sore in the region there are
many hundreds of thousands left who may
follow these if there isn't a solution
on all of which puts Malaysia and
Indonesia in a very tight spot doesn't
it because they have said the low given
temporary shelter those people who are
stuck at sea and that of course is
invaluable in saving lives in the short
term but longer-term it's not really a
solution it's not a solution and they
pledged to take those currently at sees
an estimate of six or seven thousand but
not to open their doors to further
migration and Thailand to today has said
that it's not going to push boats back
to see so it's a modest temporary
improvement
but it's not the kind of solution which
is needed which is integration of this
group into the mainstream of my own mob
politics and in general there's a lot of
change going on in mind marang Zhang
sook ji and the opposition groups
participating now in the elections and
in the parliament but no group even they
seems willing to champion this Muslim
group there is this sort of terrible
sort of Buddhist majority cultural
nationalism prevalent in the country at
the moment which is just adding to the
discrimination and to the pressure for
Exodus for this group and so we know
that the US Deputy Secretary of State is
to visit the area but can you see
international pressure being applied and
actually isn't too in that I hope so but
you know the trouble is that some of
those who usually sees the moral high
ground and get into the pulpit on this
like we Europeans were a good at doing
that haven't exactly got a spotless
record ourselves at the moment in terms
of migrants crossing the Mediterranean
and indeed the US with its problems
coming across from Mexico and Central
America you know that we all have notes
in our own eyes this issue of economic
and migration which fears onto political
refugee hood for many of the groups
leaving you know is is one which is a
growing component of our 21st century
world but we're just not gripping we're
not coming up with common shared
standards of decency towards people
forced to flee their homes and this
whole notion that cracking down on the
traffickers is actually exacerbating at
the problem is that one that you know I
think track cracking down on the
traffickers is part of the solution we
have to make it more difficult for
people to leave particularly as these
traffickers you know let people sail in
very dangerous situations and they're as
in the Mediterranean a lot of lives have
been lost because of that but cracking
down on the traffickers doesn't solve
the root problem here which is dealing
with the conditions which make people
take lives and their lives into their
own hands in this way in the first place
Obama we've got you here we've got some
developing news
and that is that we understand that is
now has control of their ancient city in
Syria Palmyra lots of fears in recent
days that this could happen it now
sounds like unfortunately it has fallen
what's your reaction well that you know
this is a gang an issue which is not
being gripped and dealt with properly
we've limit ourselves to air attacks we
have no political strategy for dealing
with the Shia Sunni divisions in the
region which are fed this and then in a
sense been the the handmaiden or the the
the Midwife of the create rather the the
creation of is and you know now we're
paying a terrible price for air attacks
plus absence of political strategy so
when either effective militarily in
containing is and absolutely lack any
way of politically trying to redress the
kind of recruiting components that have
made is happen so another example sadly
of a slightly under managed out of
control world at the moment very tragic